welcome to hannity and tonight biden
cowering in fear hiding behind a giant
no card after getting threatened by
china's dictator during an embarrassing
humiliating phone call earlier today we
have every humiliating detail coming up
plus fake moderate joe manchin sadly
caved to the radical left of his party
and now sadly the people of west
virginia they will pay the price for him
caving literally through higher taxes
and higher inflation and a much longer
recession than needed a lower quality of
life all in the name of green renewable
energy we're going to expose the
shameful hard left turn
from the west virginia senator by the
way tonight we have an interesting
question why is mayor muriel bowser
washington d.c finally now asking for
the national guard and their assistance
we'll give you that answer coming up all
right but first tonight our top story of
the day i wish it was not true but after
two straight quarters of negative growth
we are officially in a recession in 2020
this was the very definition of
recession look at that according to cnn
and cnbc and the la times and the new
york times and nancy pelosi
and pretty much every notable economist
and pretty much everyone else on earth
but your mentally impaired decrepit old
president knows better according to joe
we're definitely not in a recession in
spite of we're actually having two
consecutive quarters of negative growth
take a look
the inflation reduction act will add
another 370
billion dollars in clean energy tax
credits
in
reconciliation including incentives to
accelerate domestic production of solar
panels wind turbines batteries and
critical materials processing that
doesn't sound like a recession to me
thank you very much
thanks to everyone else with a brain
that actually believes in definitions
two straight quarters of negative growth
and now tonight we can report the
housing market which i've been warning
you about i told you this is going to
happen that a crash has now officially
begun new home construction will stop
sale of pre-existing homes that will
stop people aren't going to want to give
up their 2.8 uh percent 30-year fixed
loan or 3.8 30-year fixed loan and go
with a seven or eight percent 30-year
fixed loan they can't afford it now
foreclosures are way up and you know
that repo man from way back when yeah
motor vehicle repossessions are now also
way up we have nearly 50 percent of our
fellow americans struggling to simply
pay their bills we learned this week
consumer confidence is now at a new low
inflation remains at a 40-plus year high
gas prices still are double what they
were under donald trump even though
they're tapping the strategic petroleum
reserves which we need in case of an
emergency
and joe biden is in complete denial and
just lying to all of us that should
bother all of you the most you know just
like he lied about never talking to
hunter about his foreign business
dealings we have new evidence today we
have a report with matt gates coming up
later in the program
14 specific times joe met with hunter's
farm business partners every american
should be angry not only about his
failure as a president but the fact that
he lies and everyone else around him
tells the same lies today in a bizarre
moment biden insisting that ungrateful
americans you're all ungrateful you're
only complaining about the economy
because they have jobs instead of eight
thousand dollar checks from the
government it's your fault take a look
but i started thinking about it just as
a you know somebody who's
raised a middle class kid one year
even though you didn't have the job you
have now even though you didn't get a
raise that year
the difference between having a job
having a five percent raise or whatever
three five seven whatever it happens to
be
in the face of inflation
price of the pump although that's down
every day so far
but you know it's like whoa
i feel worse off but then again i didn't
get a check for eight grand from the
government i just among other things
does that make any sense to
anybody or is it just me
no joe it doesn't make sense it's sort
of like pete buda judge this week more
pain at the pump we have more benefit
from more pain that you experience who
knows what joe's talking about who knows
why they're adopting these insane
policies but they're hurting the entire
country and i i don't know that fed
chairman jerome powell he called today's
negative gdp report even worse than
expected maybe they should listen to him
although i don't frankly think he knows
what the hell he's doing either take a
look
so i wouldn't say it was i think we
didn't expect a good reading but this
one uh this one was was even worse than
expected i would say
um i don't talk about my own personal
estimate of of what the terminal rate
would be
um i do i will write down that in uh
it's going to evolve it's obviously it
has evolved over the course i think for
for all participants it has evolved over
the course of the year as we learn how
persistent inflation is going to be
every american needs to take note here
none of this is good but as per usual
joe biden and all the hacks and advisers
around him they just refuse to tell the
truth which again is nothing new joe was
in denial remember about afghanistan he
lied what a great success we still have
americans behind enemy lines it's nearly
one full year day 348 since he abandoned
them we have our department of homeland
security secretary mayorka saying last
week oh uh the the border's secure
it's anything but secure just the
opposite now joe light about the russian
buildup of russian troops around ukraine
oh that doesn't necessarily
mean that he's going to invade wrong
again they lied about the supply chain
they lied about not being warned about
the baby formula shortage they lied
repeatedly about the causes of spiking
gas prices they caused the price spike
because they artificially reduced the
world supply they lied over and over and
over again inflation is transitory and
now biden and everyone around him and
the media mob they're all lying about
what is a very real recession by
definition by the definition that they
themselves used two years ago in fact
today's massive spending bill and tax
hike rubber stamped by joe manchin will
make this recession our and our
inflation that much worse you can't
fight inflation by printing money and
raising taxes by the way you know who
said that joe biden i'm sorry joe
manchin and barack obama we'll play it
later now of course biden's constant
state of denial and lying has led to
serious consequences americans have died
we have others left and abandoned in
afghanistan europe is at war fentanyl is
pouring across all borders human
trafficking inside the u.s is at an
all-time high and now americans are
being crushed by joe's inflation his
record high gas prices and a brand new
recession so it's time for all of them
to stop spinning stop lying and admit to
the truth and if you can first
admit to the truth it shall set you free
and maybe you'll start thinking about a
course correction go back to securing
our border go back to energy
independence policies we need a massive
change in direction your policies are
failing the american people hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else